thanks to skillshare for helping support
this episode
hey crazies consider the following
scenario two spaceships connected by a
taut string are accelerating in exactly
the same fashion
what happens to the string does it snap
if the acceleration is the same then the
distance between them should also remain
the same so the string should not snap
right
but if they accelerate anywhere near the
speed of light length contraction
happens
so snap
but the spaceships don't observe the
length contraction and neither does the
string
so which is it does it snap or not
we can solve this but it's going to test
the limits of special relativity
[Music]
so which is it then snapped or not oh it
definitely snaps how do you know
this one took me longer to understand
than i expected so buckle up crazies
the problem we have here is called a
paradox
according to merriam-webster that's an
argument that apparently derives
self-contradictory conclusions by valid
deductions from acceptable premises
okay that's a lot of ten dollar words
essentially if you start with ideas that
you know to be true and through
different trains of thought you can
arrive at two opposing conclusions then
you've got yourself a paradox
now paradoxes aren't a problem with the
universe they're a problem with us in
other words one of our premises is
faulty
we either have a preconception we're
unaware of or we've stepped beyond the
scope of the model
this spaceship paradox is no exception
though it's actually one of the more
recent paradoxes in special relativity
to the timeline
special relativity was published in
1905. general was 10 years later
edmund dewan and michael baron wouldn't
start this paradox until 1959.
but as you can see here their solution
wasn't very thorough this is the entire
publication
it did spark a lot of discussion though
so dejuan revisited the topic in 1963
where he considered it in tandem with
the famous pole barn paradox
the debate centered around material
stress and how that should be treated
relativistically
in 1976 john stewart bell of quantum
entanglement fame finally fleshed out
the nuances by adding a third observer
to represent the previously abstract
inertial reference frame
we now refer to this as bell's spaceship
paradox i'm not sure why it ended up
named after him instead of dejuan and
barron maybe because he was more famous
i don't know
anyway let's work out some of these
nuances
say i've made three clones arthur
bernard and charles
arthur and bernard's rockets are
connected by a string exactly the length
of the gap between them
if both rockets begin accelerating at
exactly the same moment at exactly the
same rate then what happens to the
string
to be clear all observers should agree
on whether or not the string snaps
observers can disagree about when events
occur how far apart they are and even
sometimes their order but they must all
agree on which events occur
since charles is stationary he would
observe relativistic length contraction
the rockets contract in length but the
string can't because it's attached to
the rockets therefore the string snaps
under the stress
so paradox solved bingo bango not so
fast we haven't considered the other two
observers yet from the point of view of
arthur and bernard the string should be
stationary that means no length
contraction which means no snapping of
the string
and there's our contradiction our
paradox the string can't be both broken
and unbroken
all observers must agree on which events
occur
the string either snaps for everyone or
it doesn't for everyone
charles represents what we call an
inertial frame of reference
for special relativity inertial just
means stationary or moving steadily in a
space-time diagram those are always
straight paths
this means we can trust our conclusions
about what charles sees
he observes length contraction so the
string snaps
i suppose you could stop there it's the
only obvious inertial reference frame in
this scenario and we know all observers
must agree on which events occur
so we know arthur and bernard will also
see the string snap but where's the fun
in that
besides this is the science asylum if
we're going to call this paradox solved
i think our aspiration should be a bit
higher than sufficient we need to ask a
deeper question
it may be true that the string also
breaks for both arthur and bernard but
why
they don't observe the length
contraction so what's the cause of the
snap
well as i said before there are two
possibilities
we either have a preconception we're
unaware of or we've stepped beyond the
scope of the model
it's the second one isn't it huh
especial relativity can't handle
accelerations right actually no that
that's a common misconception
special relativity can handle
acceleration just fine the equations
don't look particularly elegant but they
exist and they're valid it's accelerated
frames of reference that are problematic
but even those are workable
if we're sneaky about it
in a space-time diagram accelerated
paths are hyperbolas because flat
space-time is hyperbolic
switching between inertial frames of
reference is easy you just rotate the
axis to shift to an accelerated frame of
reference you'd have to curve the axis
which officially jumps out of special
and into general relativity
we don't want to do that if we don't
have to
general relativity is nasty
what we're going to do instead is
imagine this hyperbola is just a bunch
of little straight paths if there are
enough of those tiny segments we can't
tell the difference it's mathematically
equivalent to the hyperbola
now if that sounds too much like math
hand waving to you there is a more
tangible way to visualize this
imagine there's a big set of inertial
pilots all watching an accelerated
rocket each of these new ships will be
traveling at a steady speed in a
straight line no acceleration
they're just positioned in such a way
that they're going the exact same speed
as the accelerating ship when that
accelerating ship catches up with them
we call these new reference frames
momentarily co-moving inertial frames or
mcifs they're momentarily in the same
frame of reference as the accelerating
ship it's the same as splitting the
hyperbola into a bunch of tiny straight
segments each segment being one of those
mcifs the point is special relativity
can handle accelerated reference frames
just fine
if you're careful there's no need to
invoke general relativity
we haven't stepped beyond the scope of
our model so we must have a hidden
preconception
what preconceived notion do we have it
has to do with the distance between the
rockets it changes
it changes when we first described the
scenario we said the rockets must begin
accelerating at the same moment and must
have the same acceleration rate
at the beginning everyone is stationary
relative to each other so they're all in
the same frame of reference having the
rocket start at the same moment isn't
the problem it's the acceleration rate
that's the problem there's only one
observer that measures those rates to be
the same
charles
for him the space-time paths or world
lines for arthur and bernard look like
this
since they accelerate at the same rate
their paths have the same shape the
rockets maintain a steady distance from
each other while contracting in length
but the string is attached to both ships
so it can't contract even though it's
trying to
the extra tension makes it snap
it also snaps for arthur and bernard but
for an entirely different reason because
their rockets move apart
you always measure length or distance
parallel with your own space axis hence
these distance measurements charles made
from his own frame of reference
but bernard's axes change over time if
his space axis changes then how he
measures distance also changes
bernard sees arthur accelerate too
quickly which pulls on the string making
it snap
arthur sees something similar
in his frame bernard is lagging behind
he's accelerating too slowly which pulls
on the string making it snap
there are three frames of reference and
the string snaps in all three of them it
just happens for different reasons
but
when does it break oh now we're cooking
with gas
[Laughter]
yet another assumption we've made here
is that the string is incredibly weak it
has no effect on how the rockets move
technically this string breaks
immediately you could easily choose
something stronger like a thick metal
rod or something but the stronger it is
the more it will affect how the rockets
move
if it's strong enough the rockets won't
even be independent anymore arthur will
just be towing bernard they'll act as
one object
so does the string break given our
initial setup yes in every frame of
reference
for charles the string breaks due to
length contraction for arthur and
bernard the string breaks because the
distance increases could we make the
attachment strong enough so that it
doesn't ever break
sure but then you've changed the
scenario a different scenario means a
potentially different outcome when
you're working with special relativity
you've got to be careful your personal
instincts are your own worst enemy they
can lead you down a road toward
unrealistic paradoxes and if you wander
too far you might end up answering a
different question than you wanted
speaking of questions a lot of people
ask me what i use to make my animations
it's almost exclusively after effects
which you could learn how to use by
joining skillshare
skillshare is an online learning
community with thousands of inspiring
classes for anyone who wants to explore
their creativity or learn new skills
many of my animations aren't even really
animations they're simulations i code
physics directly into after effects
using what they call expressions
skillshare has a class on this called
advanced adobe after effects by jake
bartlett i watched this class myself
recently and it was great it'll walk you
through how to make a fancy digital name
badge like this which honestly is the
perfect launching point for learning
after effects expressions
but if that's not for you skillshare
also has classes on photography graphic
design productivity and more you should
be able to find classes that match your
goals and interests
if that sounds like something you might
be interested in check out skillshare
the first 1000 people to use my special
link will get a one month free trial
it'll also let skillshare know you heard
about them from me which helps out the
channel
so are you satisfied with my solution to
the paradox please share in the comments
thanks for liking and sharing this video
a special thanks goes out to all my
patreon patrons and youtube members
don't forget to subscribe if you'd like
to keep up with us and until next time
remember it's okay to be a little crazy
a couple of you thought it was really
cool that the universe still surprises
us and i completely agree
it could just mean that our technology
is limited but it could also mean that
we're going to learn something new
personally i'm excited to see what the
james webb space telescope has to offer
anyway thanks for watching